On February 28th, 2022 a Russian attack
hit the Ukrainian city of Kharkiv
in a residential area.
Four people died collecting water from a water
point in that neighborhood
and many more were injured.
We had lots of videos from social media that were
documenting the attack from multiple angles.
Some videos taken from afar,
from high rise buildings...
Milena Marin and her team at Amnesty International
gather evidence like this
looking for signs of war crimes.
We want to see was that, in any way,
a legitimate strike.
And among the videos and photos they found
showing the destruction of civilian property
one particular piece of evidence
caught their attention.
It’s a remnant from a cluster bomb
a weapon so destructive to civilians that
its use alone
can constitute a war crime.
So why do the world’s most powerful militaries
still use them?
Cluster munition strikes involve rockets
that contain dozens or even hundreds of smaller
cluster bombs.
This is the nose cone of a rocket from another
attack in Kharkiv
and this is the tail.
The image Milena analyzed is one of the smaller
cluster bombs.
When the rocket releases cluster bombs
they scatter over an area as large as several
city blocks
causing widespread explosions.
Like this video verified by Bellingcat
taken from another attack in Kharkiv.
Each circle is one of the cluster bombs exploding.
It’s this imprecision that makes cluster
bombs illegal
under the rules of war, in most cases.
Those rules were created by a series of international
treaties that span decades.
They govern how wars should be fought.
They prohibit things like intentionally targeting
civilians.
And they ban what’s known as
"indiscriminate attacks".
Every state military has the obligation
to use as precise weapons as possible to hit
military targets and not civilian targets.
A precise attack on a military target like
a base or weapons hanger
is permissible under the law
because it intentionally avoids civilian areas.
In an area with both military and civilian
structures,
militaries have to be careful to only target
non-civilian areas.
Striking a populated, mainly-residential area,
like the attack in Kharkiv
is almost impossible to justify legally.
Especially if you are using cluster munitions.
They’re extremely bad at targeting and releasing
them anywhere near civilians
results in indiscriminate damage.
Of the roughly 23,000 documented cluster munitions
deaths worldwide since the 60s
about 94% have been civilians.
Some of that is because of the high failure
rate of the smaller bombs
up to 30% of them don’t explode on impact.
So they remain on the ground, posing a risk
indefinitely.
A vast majority of cluster munition deaths,
80%
are from these lingering remnants as opposed
to the initial strike.
These weapons sit for decades and decades
and are just as deadly and capable
when a farmer hits them with a plow
in 1970 or in 2070.
They're still going to kill and injure.
The US dropped millions of cluster bombs in
Southeast Asia
in the 60s and 70s during the Vietnam War.
Those same bombs still kill and injure hundreds
of people to this day.
Including in March of this year, when a man
in Laos was killed
by a US bomb he encountered while making a
fire to cook.
These small, metallic remnants are often brightly
colored
which is why children are attracted to them.
In Kosovo, for example, after
the Yugoslav Wars
62.5% of casualties from cluster bombs were
boys under the age of 18.
When Milena’s team at Amnesty International’s
Crisis Evidence Lab got reports
of the February 28th attack
reports of cluster bombs were just one element
they began verifying.
My team is cataloging most of the videos
that are coming from Ukraine
focusing on those that can qualify
as human rights violations
under definitions of war crimes.
It’s illegal to target civilians or to use
indiscriminate weapons.
We do a lot of research to see whether there's
weapons, hangars,
or anything that could justify an attack.
Google Earth imagery of the area, captured
before the war
only appears to show civilian structures:
high-rise apartment buildings, a hotel,
an auto parts store, and a gondola station.
The man who took the cluster bomb photo told
me he heard a mistaken military target
may have been this recreational shooting range.
So what we've done was to build a 3D model
of the neighborhoods
and overlay all of the videos and imagery
we found onto the 3D model
to really understand the footprint
of the attack.
We did that because we thought that
cluster munitions were used.
The man who took the bomb photo lives here.
He found the bomb a few meters from this parking
lot where his car was parked.
The photo got forwarded to Amnesty International
to analyze.
The manufacture date was from 2019 and
Milena’s team determined
it was a Russian-made 9N235 cluster munition,
shot from a 300mm Smerch rocket system,
like this.
All of this evidence showed that the attack
focused on civilians
nowhere near a military target, using
an indiscriminate weapon.
A potential war crime.
And everything we do is with the purpose
of justice and accountability.
Really conclusive evidence, sometimes
tends to come later on.
The rule of war banning indiscriminate attacks
was created in 1977.
But it didn’t stop countries from using
cluster munitions
in civilian-populated war zones.
Like the Soviets in Afghanistan...
NATO forces in Kosovo and Yugoslavia...
Israel in Lebanon...
and by the US in Iraq and Afghanistan.
The civilian impact of these bombings motivated
a cluster munitions treaty in 2008
which sought to ban the weapon outright.
And it included obligations to assist victims
and clean up undetonated remnants.
It was signed by over 100 countries.
But, notably, not by the worst offenders.
“We don’t have countries such as the US,
China and Russia that are major producers,
and have been users, the US and Russia of
cluster munitions.”
That means today, these non-signatory countries
still may be producing cluster munitions.
And these countries still likely stockpile
them, for different reasons.
The U.S. maintains its arsenal because
in some theoretical conflict where there's
a number of tanks
and people outside of those tanks
if you used cluster munitions on that
you could both damage the vehicles and
injure the people outside of them.
Having a weapon that does that is useful
in a military arsenal.
However, there's other weapons that do that
that don't produce thousands of duds
that can affect civilians for a long time
afterwards.
I asked Brian to compare cluster munitions
to another type of banned warfare:
chemical weapons.
The ethical and legal arguments are actually
very similar
which is the inherently indiscriminate nature
of using either weapons,
Like cluster munitions, the use of
chemical weapons
violates a ban on “indiscriminate attacks”
among other rules of war.
It’s impossible to use a gaseous weapon
in a precise way.
After their use in World War I, a Geneva protocol
banned the use of chemical weapons.
And in 1993, a chemical weapons treaty made
that ban more explicit
by also prohibiting the development, production,
and stockpiling of the weapon.
Nearly every country signed on to it.
But that level of committment just hasn’t
happened with cluster bombs
partly because chemical weapons have been
explicitly banned and stigmatized for so long.
Since the signing of the 2008 treaty,
cluster munitions are still in use.
This container and cluster bomb were used
in the last known US cluster munition strike
in Yemen in 2009.
The initial impact killed 41 civilians,
including 23 children.
Russia and the Syrian government have used
cluster munitions in Syria
which is why Syria has had the highest rate
of cluster munition casualties
since their civil war began.
And reports suggest Russia has used cluster
bombs at least 24 times in Ukraine...
a low estimate.
I interviewed a man who was wounded by
cluster munition.
He still had the pieces because the surgeon
took him out of his body and he kept them.
One of the pellets that was stuck in his body was
very distinctive as coming from a certain
kind of Russian submunition.
The mountain of evidence and the number of
indiscriminate attacks is really becoming
quite overwhelming.
Not just one attack or two attacks or ten
or a hundred, but just continuously.
Any one of these attacks would be a crime
all on their own.
Along with the international community, the
US has alleged war crimes in Ukraine.
But they haven't acknowledged their own role
in perpetuating
the use of cluster munitions
around the world.
This type of hypocrisy shows how the rules
of war
are only as strong as the worst offenders
allow them to be.
International justice and accountability is
extremely challenging
and impunity is one of the reasons why these
weapons
keep getting used again and again and again.
A potential prosecution for war crimes is why
human rights investigations are so important.
But for investigators like Milena, a criminal
trial is just the long game.
We need to show what's happening to people
trapped between the two armies.
And that hopefully will sustain the attention
on Ukraine,
will provide immediate support to the victims
would provide support to those fleeing the
country.
While the legal proceedings will last years
those people have immediate needs.